これが、俺の全財産です！
嘘です！
(ピュウピュウ)
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです！まずこれなんですけども
まずこれがホントの札束だと思った人
ノンノンノン
はいこちら1万円札に見えて100万円札でございま～
これよく見ると鼻毛が出てる...
これ何かと言いますと
1万円～が100枚
もしこれが1万円札だったら
100枚分あるぐらいの札束なんで
まあ実質100万円分ぐらいだったしても過言ではないでしょう
こういうちょっと偽物っぽい形をした『メモ帳』になっております。
1番下で3億5000万
3億…6000万！
(3億)7000(万円)
(3億)8000(万円)
(3億)9000(万円)
4億(円)
4億1000(万円)
4億2000(万円)
4憶3000(万円)
4憶4000(万円)
4憶5000(万円)
4憶6000(万円)
4億7000(万円)
4億8000…(万円)
4億8500万(円)ですね
こちらにですね。4億8500万円分のメモ帳があります(笑)
本物ではありません!
が！1度私はやってみたかった…
あくまでもボクはこれを本物の札束と見立てて
4億8500万円分のお金に見えるメモ帳を使って
札束のお風呂に入ろうと思います!!!
あの～。自己満です。
で今回やりたいことは
まずその札束のお風呂に入ること
その札束に入ってるワイを見た後輩たちはどう思うのかっていう…
wwwwwww
嫌でしょ?
だって、もしさ、来てさ
俺が札束のお風呂入ってたらどうする？
静かに閉めますね。扉を
いる？
(ビヨヨヨーン)
そんな僕が札束風呂に入ってて
もしそれを見た後輩は果たして
どう思うのかやっていきたいと思います。
ではいこう!
(ピュウピュウ)
ビニールからとるとなんかテカテカ感がなくなって
それこそ偽物感がすごいんですよね
中身は真っ白なんで
取るとﾁｮｯﾄ偽物感がすごい出ちゃうんで…
ビニールに入ったままの方がなんかすごいリアルなので
このままいかせて頂きます
では…
札束風呂にいくぞー！…
よし。運ぶぞよー
「「せーの」」
まって×7
(運搬中)
どうする
ひいいいいいぃ！(奇声)
というわけで無事、下まで持ってきました。
(キラリ―ン)
来る前に僕が何とか札束のお風呂に入っとるシーンを作っちゃって
で、僕呼びます!「タオルとってえ」って
で「タオルとってえ」で入った瞬間
ちらっと見えた、垣間見えた姿が、
札束に入る俺っていう。
wwwwwww
設定でございますｗ
では！SET
(偽札投入中)
見て(小声)
wwwwwwww
(ビヨヨヨーン)
刺さるなぁ～...
ぴゅうう～～
まさきー！
まさきー！(2回目)
はい？(まさき)
「バスタオルとってえ」
多分右の方にあると思う
「バスタオルとってえ」(2回目)
多分、あの、置くところにあると思う
www
わああああ！(奇声)
れってーれってーれってーれってー
てーれれれれーれー
てれれれー
てれれれーれー
てれれれーれれれ
てれれれーれーれー
でゅふでゅふでゅふ、ふふふふ
いつも通りじゃねーか(まさき)
ｗｗｗ
あのぉ～入った感想言わせていただきますと、
すげえ痛いんだよね。
だろうねｗ
角とかヤバそう
すっごい痛い
ほら見てみてほら！
ほら！
さ、札でここだからね。もう。